what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm doing
something a little bit different i am
going to be reacting
to 90 day fiance videos um
just something kind of different before
i start oh wrong one
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily
videos all right you guys ready i'm
pumped
you know i tell you a story my mom she
uh she always says something that she
always says she says nothing
nothing stays the same but your aunt
debbie
and she said that my whole life aunt
debbie is true to the bone
true the true the core always always
will be
i hate to say it but you can always tell
who the
fiance my point is cole i think that you
know
you owe a bit of respect
you don't understand that deb is not the
scent that you
paint regardless
this is her this is her son what i'm
talking about is respecting
her is respecting her as an elder and
knowing what she's
going through you have each other don't
you
you have each other you have each other
what does she have
god i have no idea i do not know the
backstories of any of this
but i have no idea what they're fighting
about
just because she's got a mother she's
alone to make
my life a hell like she did that's true
some mother-in-laws
are crazy i have no idea the situation
but
i'm i'm team that girl you have a man
paying for you oh oh i just switched
sides
your man pays for everything because you
don't do a
thing right now and until you do and you
understand
respect you're not actually going to
understand
the truth about debbie or colt or
america
at all because cole obviously is
infatuated with you
he loves both of you guys and if you
guys love him you guys gotta work this
out
so that he can have both of you in his
life and that's a big ass ring
so you should feel like a damn queen
with a rock like that
but no you take advantage
oh damn i switched sides i'm on team
that guy
hey you know what don't say i just go
with because he's a sweetheart and i
love him
wayne don't say that i would like to
take advantage of the coat of this love
because adventure what because
not millionaire coty having a car with
you
no no air conditioner so what kind of
advantage are you taking
using his body maybe the only adventure
that i take
i mean if you still pay for everything
you can't discount that
dude i swear to god we'll see
we'll see we'll see
that is for his money period
you think about riches and glory and
glam and all this stuff
your lucky one because he deserves
better he deserves better
stop it welcome to vegas
how does he not say anything at all i
can't pretend anymore it's just this
is fake that's not true love i'm sorry
that's just a lie
love is enduring for the other loving
fighting for the others
oh okay what do you think that you are
and everyone that's against
of love is absolutely delusional
damn confusing you don't know who what
love is what respect is you don't know
what it is
to have a marriage or a true meaningful
life
and i like how the fiance is just
sitting there
doing nothing like either take your
brother's side or your wife's side i
can't really
handle someone that is completely
irrational and yells and screams and
i wish everyone just calmed down and
talked things through
don't come tomorrow no don't come too
much no i don't care to come to your
working wedding night i swear to god
once the surgery starts it'll only take
about
six minutes for the baby to be into the
world
oh no my heart beat
so fast waiting for
bronte baby so they're cutting they're
cutting right now
they're making the incision this is the
intense part
they literally cut you open
i'm just very freaking
prepare yourself they're almost to the
baby
[Music]
i'm confused i thought this was 90 days
he's so perfect he's so perfect
oh my god i am so
overwhelmed and happy he's so handsome
oh it's love at first sight and it's the
most
overwhelming feeling you'll ever feel in
your lifetime
oh my god that baby's ugly i'm not even
gonna lie to you
like it's a cute moment but oh that
baby's not cute
[Music]
but heartbroken why
[Music]
i'm sorry i don't know any of the back
stories oh we got a new
[Music]
not anymore yeah cause you got your ass
kicked to the curb
i never did his adjustment of status so
at this point
he's here illegally so he used to go
oh oh okay the the cop oh i'm getting
chills cause
they're like on a mission they're
serious
oh i mean i feel bad for him in a sense
but he put himself in a bad situation i
know
i feel bad for everybody who cries yeah
the tears even flowed there's a little
cry damn
is he crying are them real tears though
no oh now you want to wear the ring no
not that i'm even crazier but i think
you got off kind of easy
and then walks off look she said you got
off easy got off easy bye
[Music]
like not even kidding i'm so confused i
do not know the backstory to any of
these
that was entertaining though um i can't
believe everyone i'm a little confused
at how the one guy
had a baby if they only knew each other
for 90 days
but who am i who am i to judge
let me know in the comments if you guys
like these type of reactions if you do
leave a comment let me know don't forget
to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell i'll talk
to you guys next time